Karissa our hearts are racing everybody
is wondering what in the world just
transpired for the last few moves in
that final second were you watching that
game um no I actually wasn't I was in
bed being sad about how I threw away
everything in attempt to to win um so
yeah I was really in like the depths of
my Despair and then I got a call from
like a bunch of people and they were
like
you have to come back to the club
because you're going to be the new
champion and I was like what this what a
nice story this must be such an
intriguing way to win a championship
right you went through the spectrum of
all possible emotions out there you were
obviously exhilarated winning so many
games one after the other but then those
last couple of rounds you are half a
point behind you come back leate prag
your opponent then this final round
first of all how did you strategize in
your mind this final round were you
thinking that this is a must-win
situation for
you um not really I was sort of like you
know a draw would be okay um but then I
got to the board and while I was playing
I was like you know what actually I
would really rather win um I don't know
I just like I really thought begum would
win and I was like I I don't want to
play another day of
Chess um not not cuz you know I hate the
game or anything but it's just like for
the last month or so I've been playing
Non-Stop and I was like another playoff
and I'll have to prep again and I'm
really behind on all my homework I was
planning on using tonight to catch up on
that um so I was like I'm going to I'm
going to win this game and in The Rook
end game it really felt like I was
pressing um but then I was just like low
on on the clock blundered
everything and I was I was so sad and I
was like you know what like I don't even
deserve to be a champion if you know I'm
making these sorts of blenders in a
position where I just need a draw and
where I like had a draw um so I was
super disappointed in
myself but luckily things worked out
okay I guess absolutely and you had the
opportunity by the way to repeat the
position a few times and even in that
last final moves it was that idea of
going Rook to G3 and Rook to G1 started
with a move
C7 when you play the move C7 did you
realize that after Rook to F1 you
lost I think I played B5 but I was just
yeah I had spent so much time beforehand
you know um I kind of saw my way up to
this position and for some reason I just
missed that after Rook f F1 Rook G1 King
somewhere I mean Rook G3 King somewhere
Rook G1 black just has Rook D1 and I was
like spending all my time calculating
Rook df6 um so it's just like a terrible
terrible miscalculation in it um so you
were looking at F6 here this is what you
were
cating yeah and then White's just doing
great here but I just missed RI D1
completely um I don't know blind spot I
guess
and yeah once it was played on the board
I was like um once I saw this s ricky1
idea I was like oh my God like yeah I
kind of threw away everything and I was
like checking begum's game at the same
time and everything and uh for some
reason I still thought that you know I
should try to fight for the win but I I
really shouldn't have um but yeah this
is kind of a mistake that I make a lot
of the times but hopefully this will be
the last but Karissa have to uh we have
to replay this final moment of the final
second that Jennifer had on her clock
did you see this and take us through
your emotion when you're seeing it right
now as a
replay
two
[Music]
one wow 1 second on the I I think that
was less than one second way less than
one second
I mean it's different now that I know
the result of the game but uh you know
if I was watching it live I would
be I'll be scared but I think since the
broadcast is on a the broadcast is on a
delay um so I wasn't seeing the most
this the first time stuff yeah wow wow
well Karissa I'll give you guys the
floor right now just an incredible don't
want the floor you just exhaust I want
the
ceiling congratulations Carissa we're
going to leave it there I mean just wow
uh amazing amazing amazing stuff we were
watching Jennifer make her move with one
second on the clock and we were just
like wow how does that one second last
so long but I do have to admire like
your spirit to really push for the draw
draw I mean push for the win at all cost
kind of risking that I was so terrified
when the pawn was on E2 and I was like I
would just go for Perpetual I'm scared
something is going to happen so uh you
know that's why you're a better player
than me that's why I'm not a better
player because I'm you know too kind of
maybe worried but you just kind of were
calculating and it didn't work out this
time but maybe it's going to work
another because you had that fighting
spirit thank you our congratulations
again as we close the show I'm just
looking for